Ці страуси прославилися на всю Україну 5 років тому
після втечі Віктора Януковича, коли люди побачили,
яку резиденцію вибудував собі екс-президент.
- Ці б’ються ногами. Розмах крил, лапа - як футболіст.
Цей красень на прізвисько Жорик, схоже,
в чудовій формі. А це - його подруги і, судячи з усього,
без Януковича їм живеться дуже весело.
Поголів'я страусів за ці роки навіть збільшилося:
тепер у "Межигір'ї" майже десять страусів
і їм добудували вольєри.
- Ось та худоба, яка нам залишилась від Віктора Федоровича,
за часи його правління.
А вже решта - те, що ви зараз побачили, -
це наше хозяйство.
Іншої живності за ці роки тут побільшало.
Колись Януковича "обслуговували" лише 6 корів, нині - 26.
Крім того, в господарстві водяться кози, лами,
олень, барани, віслюки, індики та фазани.
Активісти, які взяли під свій контроль
резиденцію "Межигір’я" ще у 2014-му, запевняють,
що на совість доглядають усіх тварин. Щоправда,
витрати на якісний корм із кожним роком важче покривати.
- Близько 150 000 гривень на місяць потрібно.
Наразі ці кошти отримують з туристів:
квиток до резиденції коштує не менше 40 гривень.
За часів Януковича, як з’ясували активісти за документами,
що знайшли в "Межигір'ї", це все господарство
оплачувалося з держбюджету через доволі заплутані схеми
Держуправління справами президента і
підконтрольної Януковичу компанії "Танталіт", яка
і досі де-юре залишається власником більшості майна,
що є в "Межигір’ї". Ось цієї теплиці, приміром,
де екологічно чисті овочі вирощують
за нідерландськими технологіями: ані краплі хімії.
- Ви можете скуштувати томат.
Це дійсно як запах літа.
Аби теплиця покривала зарплату кільком працівникам,
овочі продають туристам і прихильникам здорового харчування.
Теплиця могла б приносити значно більше доходу,
якби налагодити співпрацю з дорогими супермаркетами.
- Для того, щоб вони зацікавилися, ми повинні мати сертифікат.
Для того, щоб мати сертифікат, ми повинні мати статус.
Ми його не маємо, і виходить замкнене коло.
Цим колом, зізнаються тут, вже втомилися ходити.
Спочатку активісти Майдану зберігали майно,
яке отримало статус покинутого. Вони вимагали
від Генпрокуратури хоча б описати його.
У 2016-му це нарешті сталося, хоча описали далеко не все.
Після того, як активісти заснували
громадську організацію "Національний парк "Межигір’я",
їм передали  на зберігання лише описане майно,
але по факту стежать за всім.
Водночас суд арештував майно "Межигір’я", однак
теж не все. Інший суд потім передав це АРМА -
Національному агентству з розшуку і управління активами корупціонерів.
І вийшла, за оцінками активістів, вельми заплутана юридична ситуація.
- Слідчі фотографували і писали, що є стільки-то корів.
Просто уявляєте, в юридичному полі  - накласти арешт на корову?
Просто вже комічна ситуація.
Теплиця арештована, але вона не передана АРМА.
Взагалі ландшафт не описаний  і не накладений арешт,
а це десятки мільйонів доларів.
З "Хонкою" Януковича - те саме.
Деякі поверхи і все, що на них, передали АРМА, деякі - ні.
Приміром, цей люксовий спа-салон з усіма
омолоджувальними технологіями.
Активісти очікували, що ідея АРМА провести конкурс
і знайти підприємство, яке б управляло
резиденцією і заробляло б для держави кошти,
змінить ситуацію. Проте, окрім самих активістів,
зацікавленість виявив лише один учасник.
Конкурс поки не відбувся. АРМА визнає:
черги з охочих заробити на колишній резиденції Януковича немає.
Занадто ризикований це об’єкт, адже за п'ять років
юридичні права так і не врегулювали: хоча "Хонка",
майно в ній і довколишня територія арештовані
рішенням суду, однак де-юре, як і раніше, належать
підконтрольній Януковичу фірмі "Танталіт".
Сам екс-президент визнаний судом винним
поки лише за держзраду. Рішення про конфіскацію його майна немає.
- Поки є два кримінальні провадження, які ніяк
не доведуть до логічного завершення.
Має бути доведено прокурором,
що це було надбано злочинними способами,
значить, воно має повернутися в державну власність.
А якщо прокурори не зможуть це довести,
а адвокати фірми Януковича "Танталіт" скажуть, що
це все було в рамках закону і по-чесному,
тоді це має повернутися фірмі "Танталіт" Януковича.
На утримання резиденції раніше, згідно
зі знайденими активістами документами, офіційно
витрачали понад 4 мільйони доларів на місяць.
Нині ж на туристах у місяць заробляють
у середньому 3 мільйони гривень. "Хонці" ж
необхідна недешева профілактика.
Зовнішні дерев'яні стіни треба регулярно обробляти олією.
І всередині теж постійно потрібно щось ремонтувати.
- Ось приклад халтури. Усуваємо потроху.
Петро Олійник є незмінним комендантом "Хонки" ще з 2014-го.
Він вважає, що найкращим варіантом було б
зробити тут музей корупції, а резиденції офіційно
надати статус національного парку.
Тим часом АРМА звинуватила самих активістів
у незаконній підприємницькій діяльності
на території "Межигір'я" і що вони нібито самі
розкрадають резиденцію. Петро такі закиди
відкидає і каже, що без громадського контролю
резиденцію вже давно спіткала б доля інших
розграбованих маєтків Януковича і його "сім'ї",
які були під охороною держави.
Від них залишилися хіба що ось ці кітчеві картини.